all right guys
bang bang i've got basically here thank
you so much for doing this sir
thanks for having me on pomp really
excited to uh run through and jam on
a million things that we have to talk
about all bitcoin related
all hype fest i'm really excited to be
on with you today
all right let's get after let's just go
through your background real quick uh
where'd you grow up and what did you do
before you got to bitcoin
yeah and and a lot of that will actually
lead you know how i got into it so i
grew
up actually in st louis missouri my
family came from a wood manufacturing
background so my
my grandfather founded a wood
manufacturing called jmc wood in the
1970s
my father runs that company today it's
in bridgeton missouri um and that
actually led me to bitcoin mining
um so in 2016 we had we had warehouses
and machinery
we had some excess power and just space
you know and and what you see
within the mining space is you know lean
and mean operations so i was just
thinking like what can i do with this
energy in space and that led me to
the bitcoin mining rabbit hole um in
2016 the s9 was just released
so i just started filling and building
racks in my dad's like warehouse and
these
workers and employees were looking at me
like i was an alien
and we just started hashing and then
from there um i saw
you know a lot of opportunity right
fragmentation in the market
um you know us miners struggling to to
order machines
the value of like the s9s i bought in
early 2017 like ten folding
um and and and it really just led to the
formation of blocker solutions um which
i
co-founded with uh my late and great
business partner matthew de souza
who you had on your podcast last year
you know rest in peace god bless
uh what an amazing person and then sam
schwerzinski uh who's our current cfo
um and and we're still uh vertically
integrating and doing a lot of really
nice things today
um i went to the kelly school of
business and at iu i had a bs in finance
and a master's degree in information
systems
prior to just going full-time blockchain
i worked in
management consulting and i was a lead
solution engineer at a
risk management software company awesome
so when you start mining bitcoin how do
you get from that
to blockware so um
great points so what so what blockwhere
is is it's a vertically integrated
uh bitcoin mining um and you know
general blockchain oriented company
um so just to give a background on
blackwear and what it is
um first and foremost we're a wholesaler
and large distributor of asics
um and you know just just a fun throw
out you know what is asicsand for i give
this all the time application specific
integration
integrated circuits so think of an asic
like a high-powered server that you know
runs 24 7
and just its goal is to generate and
mine bitcoin and validate the network
um and validate the communication that
happens between nodes so blocker has
actually sold over 200 000 the bitcoin
mining machines are asics since in
section in 2017
um so that's one of our key offerings
with that you know
as a as a client you may ask you know
where do i put these machines right um
so we host the machines
blockers place over 45 megawatts of of
hosting equipment across different
colocation facilities and and over time
with our vertical integration we
actually co-partnered
and started and desired to operate our
own facilities
um so we're a part of a facility in
kentucky that currently has about 20
megawatts running
and um as i go into blackboard mining as
an nc as well
my second entity we actually just got a
financing and sale and lease back to
build
our second site in kentucky which will
which will start out at 25 megawatts and
scale to 100.
um and if you're following kentucky news
there's actually a really interesting
bill that was just passed
that is incentivizing bitcoin miners to
come to kentucky
and they're and which is you know
amazing and great you great news um
so really excited that we were already
in kentucky this bill comes out
and our second our second load is coming
and then and it was just like the
perfect time perfect place for that
um and then just to finish the blockbird
blurb we write industry
reading uh leading research so i'm going
to cover some of our research today
i think we we're writing a really nice
piece and it'll be researched and
available on our website
the title is uh bitcoin market outlook
um in 2021 40 000 is only the beginning
and pot between me and you we've got an
amazing top track to run through there
um and then also we all we we operate a
bitcoin mining tool
a lot of my messaging is and key
messaging um that that you'll hear me
say and i'm sure you resonate with as
well is
hey guys we need to get bitcoin in the
hands of americans and we need to get
bitcoin hash rate in the hands of
americans
um it's a it's a global race right now
let's not lose this race let's get the
messaging out
get bitcoins in our hands um we we need
to make moves now uh the time is now
um absolutely so let's get into the
research report because i think that
that's such like a
bold statement uh maybe not for somebody
talking to me but
for most people to hear 40 000 is only
just the beginning
um and you've basically broken this
report out into eight different sections
i figured maybe we could kind of go
through each section and give us a
little overview
of exactly you guys talking there and
help people
uh go and download it but the first
section is all about mining rigs and
kind of record demand
elaborate on that a little bit yeah um
and
real quickly before we do that i did
want to touch on my second entity
um my other business partner michael
stolzner he's
has 30 years of derivative trading it's
block reminding it's actually our
investment vehicle
um so i do i did want to uh you know
highlight that we are a self miner
ourselves so we'll have within block
reminding we'll have 300 pentahash
of hash um that would be online by
mid-february
um we have over 200 hosted clients um
that's our investment vehicle and that's
how we raise capital it's our sister
company to block our solutions
um and that's that's the entity that
truly is you know gonna have ownership
of these hosting facilities and
co-partnerships
but i agree with you let's jump right
into the meat and potatoes of the
research report
um so so starting with the first section
i'm talking about a record demand for
rigs
um so what what you're seeing in this
space right now actually um
is institutional participation as it
becomes to
as as it relates to mining rigs um so if
you look at an institution
um and it's amazing what we're seeing
right now we view this
this bitcoin uptrend as being fully
institutionally driven
um so with that as it relates to mining
rigs you're seeing institutions
that are investing hundreds of millions
if not billions of dollars on mining
rigs and infrastructure
um so not only do you have to buy the
bitcoin mining rig you have to spend
you know billions or hundreds of
millions on the infrastructure to host
the money
um the mining rings um so because the
institutions have entered
um it's caused nine plus plus month
delays
um for you know a retail miner or for
somebody that reaches out to these
manufacturers to buy the machines
you see companies like mara like riot
like bit farms like foundry
on these companies are buying up tens of
thousands of
machines at a time and buying future
batches
um so be so right now you're seeing lead
times of nine plus months because of the
institutional participation
um and and that's fascinating um so it's
not only
institutions you know driving and buying
bitcoin it's institutions sucking up all
the bitcoin mining rigs which creates
you know lead times that are off the
charts than what we have never seen
before
they want a bitcoin they're going to
either buy it or they're going to get
their uh their mining rigs
uh the second section is all about uh
google searches talk a little bit about
that
yeah totally um so so what what we've
seen that is really interested if you
remember in the bull market of 2017
um google searches were at an all-time
high um
and there's you know this we we source
google trends um so there was you know
hundreds and thousands and millions of
views um as it related to
you know just searching for bitcoin or
bitcoin mining right now what we found
was fascinating was that
we're at 50 percent of the levels that
we were at in 2017
um so that just signals to us that
retail has yet to enter
um it's you know it's an indicator that
um you know the retail frenzy has not
begun
and if you if you think about the cycle
of bitcoin and what happens in you know
different commodities and equities
retail is the last enter right
um they jump in after all the smart
money came in or the the institutional
investors came in so you know that's an
indicator that
um we have not seen retail participate
as it relates
um to this cycle um and we expect that
google trends to uptick towards the end
of the bull market cycle and that that
could indicate that
um the bull cycle is over right
absolutely the next section is all about
a bitcoin exchange activity
elaborate on that one yeah so so what
we've what we've done here is we've
looked at
um and really honed in on three major
exchanges uh
bitfinex coinbase and cme and if you
track over time
you know from 2018 to 20 um 20 um
bitfinex for example you know completely
dominated across the board
um we've seen them you know lose market
share um coinbase you know has you know
stably you know held market share and
you know has
you know from q1 2018 to q4 2020 you
know very similar volumes
but the most fascinating thing of this
is you'll see the cme volume
so cme from q1 all the way up to uh
q1 2018 and q1 2019 um you know was was
just about even with the others in q2
2019 you saw cme explode
um and that what when and the reason why
that's so important is because cme
um is is by is uh driven by institutions
um in order to trade us a bitcoin
futures contract on the cme
you have to uh put up five bitcoins
which is you know 175
seven thousand dollars in today's uh day
and age um and if you look at q4 2020
cme leads the pack as far as
um the quantity of bitcoin traded versus
the other two
got it and then this whole idea of uh
the institutions come in
and they only buy bitcoin they don't buy
all coins explain this one
yeah this this is a great one um and
and so if you look in 2017 um what we
saw
was you know a recharge driven market um
so so
at that time bitcoin was actually at its
lowest mark lowest market dominance and
it was around
um that time that you you
really saw like that crazy ico craze
right and that that caused bitcoin's
market dominance
fall you know to 35 um compared to where
it's at today
um and then you know over time as
institutions take over and participate
we see you know the bitcoin dominance
research um and and right you know
right now um institutions really don't
have a gateway into
um alt coins like they do with bitcoin
right um institutions can buy bitcoin
through
proven retail and exchanges and cme um
they can
they can but they can trust the customer
custody providers like coinbase
um like gemini um blackfly is building
some really
interesting things in that market you
just don't see that same type of
custody and availability um i will note
that ethereum
futures contracts will start trading on
the cme in early february
um so that could change the script and
it's not like we're necessarily
saying that institutions never will buy
into altcoins but
they're certainly bitcoin focus and and
you know that is fact
and and one a little a little bit
further what we'll cover is you know
some of the highlights and news that
took place
um with with these public companies that
have entered the market
absolutely and central bank monetary
policy seems to be everyone's favorite
topic right now
yeah uh cover that one that's a good one
and
we're kind of jumping across the board
here um so
what i love about bitcoin and and you
know what many people love about bitcoin
is
is um the monetary policy of bitcoin is
driven by code
right now central banks and or central
entities
um control the monetary policy which
which is you know
highly discouraging um so if you look um
just from a from a perspective
of of us dollar supply
in 2020 we saw circulation increased by
over 24
in the course of one year and now let's
back date
um 75 percent of all usd
um that that ex that is
is present today did not exist um so
that is
an oh my god factor that i'm sitting
here thinking hyperinflation
hyperinflation
um 2020 proved once again you know that
central bank monetary
policy is a dominant there's a
dominating force behind equity markets
and
and really what's happening is um the
government's you know pumping stimulus
and pumping treasury bonds and buying
uh you know buying uh you know through
treasury bonds um
into corporations and and every asset
that seems to be not usd fiated has
moved
um i was i was laughing to myself the
other day you know all those collected
baseball cards in like the 90s like
baseball card values have like vastly
appreciated in 2020
um everything is going up um when you
when you factor that in as well you know
um this kind of also created the perfect
storm for bitcoin so you saw that march
bottom of you know 3 800.
um people started to perk up and say you
know what's my best counter against
inflation
and that and the answer is becoming
bitcoin and that's and that's
why and why we believe a lot of the
participation has taken place
kind of created the perfect storm um you
know
infinite qe negative incident rates um
you know all this
are creating a lot of um
skepticism against you know on the us
dollar in the future
um and and this is just you know not
just backed up by data but you know
you see the legendary money makers
billion dollar corporations
even insurance companies uh we you know
like mass mutual just recently entered
they're also you know proving that this
is true they believe
um that bitcoin you know is a true hedge
against inflation and
and the digital gold narrative exists
absolutely
and what's so interesting to me about
this one i think is uh most of the other
things that you've talked about are
reactive right in terms of like hey we
can look at this and
measure uh progress based on what people
are doing this one is really
uh kind of uh proactive right in the
sense that
this is driving action this is forcing
people to go and move assets is that
kind of how you look at it as well oh i
i completely resonate with you it's a
total reactive
um and just to highlight you know some
of the few things that are the reactive
is
citibank putting out a report saying
called 21st century gold
they speculated bitcoin would be at 318k
by the end of 2021.
morgan stanley uh owns and acquires
uh 10.9 percent of microstrategy i put
out an interesting tweet
today that event you know essentially
proves out that they actually own
like indirectly by owning microstrategy
like over 7 000 bitcoin which is
fascinating is that you know
guggenheim releasing that they believe
bitcoin is going to hit 400 000.
jpmorgan chase you know who in the past
was
definitely anti-bitcoin you know put out
their speculation that you know bitcoin
will hit 146 000.
recent news goldman sachs is thinking
about offering custody service you have
standing drunken miller paul tudor jones
entering um you have mass
mutual square cash at um paypal i'm
really excited to see what paypal you
know reports for their next quarter
earnings which are on you know february
3rd
um it'll it'll be interesting to see the
volumes and their talk tracker on that
and then
you know one of the ultimate evangelists
that you know we can't
miss here is is michael saylor um you
know he's he's been
he's been the the guy on twitter and
he's
he's truly you know been an evangelist
for bitcoin
absolutely uh bitcoin market today
in 2021 versus the historical cycle in
2017 there's a whole section
uh in the paper on this what uh what
stuck out to you here
yeah so if we're looking at um
historical cycles
and as it relates to um where we're at
today
um you can see you can see that we're in
the early stages so if you look at you
know prior um bitcoin
runs um the average volatility or you
know
or downtrend during these bull cycles is
about 30.53 percent
we saw we saw that 27 drop you know
happen
you know a couple weeks ago um which is
really you know nominal compared
to some of the prior um runs that took
place um what
and and what's really important to put
out is and align to is is the having
cycles right
um if you look at all the prior having
so there's there's been three havings
um since um bitcoin was incepted right
in 2012 and 2016 and 2020
bitcoin dictated by code has a having
every four years right
um that's where the bitcoin rewards are
cut in half therefore
um you know the reward next year will go
from 6.25
and be cut in half in 2024. if you look
at
bitcoin's performance in the havings in
the having year
on the average return in the year of the
having is 206
if you look at the average return year
after
the having it's three thousand four
hundred percent
so with that being said um and and you
know don't quote me on this but we're
looking at analytics and doing some
comparisons
bitcoin at the end of 2021 if we're
looking at a 300
you know 3 400 percent gain that would
put it at 700
000 by the end of 2021.
do you think that's where it's going my
honest take is you know i'm definitely
conservative i will not be surprised if
bitcoin crosses 100k
um this is simply looking at where the
prior having
cycles are at and and just like you you
know i
it's so hard to forecast um but you can
look at data to try to help you
what what was it from january 2017 to
december 2017 it was like 20x like a
thousand to 20 000.
yes yeah exactly that it was insane i
remember
it was like that it was from
thanksgiving until december 31st where
we literally went from like a thousand
to eighteen thousand
i mean if that happened uh what did we
start the year forty thousand so it
would be like
you know you start seven
it's exactly that 34 100 return and
it's fascinating and each i mean it's
crazy um
and and that's the year after the having
year which is this year um
and and i love it and if you look at the
2020 having here bitcoin hit 304
if you look at um you know the return
rate of that year
[Laughter]
[Music]
can i quote you as saying you think it's
going to 700 000 this year
no you cannot but you vote but when my
research report is is
is out and we have all of our data and
facts inside of there um
for all those that want to you know find
this research report go to blocker
solutions.com
research and publications it's in there
um and if it goes to 700k
um you know i'll expect you to send me a
nice little bottle of champagne on
december 31st
we can drink it together i'll make you a
deal if bitcoin goes to 700
000 this year which i do not expect it
to do at all but if that happens
not only when will i come back and pull
this up uh and i will tweet it out and
say that you were right
but two is in new york i'll get dinner
with you once we're allowed to
and uh and we'll go laugh about it
because that is that is a a wild thing
but data's data right and
if uh if that's what the average returns
are then uh
your your math makes sense it's just a
question of
does uh prior uh or previous you know
history
actually predict the future well exactly
and you know
you know that's something you know if
you you know i took ap us history what
what what is something you learned
you know history repeats itself so it's
always good to study the past to try to
understand and protect the future
um i'll take you up on that we'll see if
it happens you know obviously
everyone will be a happy man if it
happens it's me you and and the whole
bitcoin band camp
absolutely amazing all right so when you
kind of look at this
uh institutions when they come in what
are they doing are they buying bitcoin
or are they buying mining equipment
is it like 80 20 one or the other what
are you guys seeing right now
so um what i'm seeing right now is some
fascinating inflows
um i i believe that um you're
you have public participants like you
know square like
um you know some of these hedge funds
that are taking percentages of you know
um purchases and microstrategy that are
buying um you know bitcoin
um you know usually otc and you know the
hundreds of millions of them out
i wouldn't be surprised in q1 of 2021 if
we've had
inflows of you know between 100 million
to billion dollar tranches that are
private and public institutions that
have made purchases
so i wouldn't be surprised if we see a
lot of releases of information that
show that um this company purchased this
amount and it's and
it'll show up on their asset books they
may have not reported it now
um then then you take a look at these
you know public mining
companies and what they're doing um so
really i'd say it's skewed right now
towards uh most of the money is flowing
into purchases of bitcoin
um but but what you're seeing with these
public companies is they're in
you know and you know foundry being you
know a part of digital currency group
which
which you know everyone knows of
grayscale they're capturing a
ton of the of the accumulation that's
taking place and we have a whole nice
chart and a research report that shows
that um
so that also documents you know that
this is institutionally driven
but if you look at you know what some of
the public companies are doing and you
know how they've performed in the market
you know they're they're putting all
their eggs into the bitcoin mining
basket right
um they're investing the hundreds of
billions hundreds of millions and
billions of dollars
into mining rigs and infrastructure um
with
with the expectation um that
these machines they buy will last three
to five years they're buying an asset
that you know they're not gonna
you know spot trade or doesn't have
liquidity right there certainly is a
secondary market but these companies
aren't buying these machines to just
you know capture an appreciation flip
them and sell them they're buying to
mine them
you know hold the bitcoin and they're
and they're buying them because they're
hyper bullish on bitcoin you know going
forward
um so seeing seeing really you know the
emergence of these public companies like
mara
like uh riot um who i'm a part of on the
advisory board
like bit farms um and a few other names
you know
putting their eggs in this basket is
fascinating and i will not be surprised
if there's a lot more public companies
that are you know
that will start doing the same um
there's certainly others like
os um um hud 8 which actually fidelity
owns 11
of um so it's fascinating to see that
when you think about corporations uh and
then coming into the market we talked a
lot about institutions kind of financial
service companies
uh when the institutions come or when
the corporations come in are they
putting bitcoin on the balance sheet
yeah they're putting they're putting it
on as treasury right um you know that's
exactly what microstrategy does
it it's it's shown on the ballots on the
balance sheet um
man i love looking at microstrategy's uh
balance sheet with
with what they've done in the timing
they made their bitcoin investment and
and if you look at how much their
stock's been appreciated um
it's it's really interesting but yes
bitcoin is going in treasury
it's on the balance sheet they're
they're capturing you know their
quarterly
revenue um you know there's there's
certainly tax implications as to you
know when they sell or how long they
hold
so you know strategically it makes sense
for them to at least hold that for a
year
these companies i don't believe they're
not buying to just buy bitcoin and sell
the tax i think they're buying with a
long-term vision that extends you know
five ten you know twenty
maybe hundred year cycles yeah it's a
counter against inflation
yeah it is uh it is absolutely wild to
watch corporations considering this
but uh i gotta imagine a lot of
boardrooms around the uh around the
country
publicly traded and privately traded
companies are all considering
you know should we go put one percent of
our assets or five percent of our assets
uh into bitcoin and then you've got
people like michael saylor who's you
know
was he 85 90 maybe 95 percent of his
balance sheets in bitcoin and
seems to be working out pretty well for
him oh yeah and i mean he also
uh purchased personally like 177 000
bitcoin himself as a side trade
um i think i think what really will
trigger
like a massive run is when we start
tapping into pension funds and i've seen
you write about this as well like
imagine capturing like between one and
five percent of pension funds
i mean this this is you're talking one
to five percent of trillions of dollars
i mean that would be the boom um a stat
that you can look at too
is um you know and this is what everyone
talks about and everyone you know peter
shifts like
a hilarious person to follow and and on
the side you know he's like he brings
awareness to bitcoin
more more so than his his down talk does
and he has a whole
following of people that troll every one
of his posts but if
if bitcoin doubles gold's market cap
bitcoin
value per coin will be a million dollars
um so
as we slowly take on and and consume
bitcoins
mark gold's market cap with bitcoin as a
digital gold narrative
um you're just going to see that price
appreciation and you know it's already
taking place you know there's websites
that are just
tracking by the minute you know bitcoins
at this level and yeah
and there's those tweets go out which i
love to see
foregone conclusion in my opinion i
absolutely think that's uh that's what's
gonna happen here but uh
hey what do i know i'm just a guy on the
internet who uh
who happens to have a lot of conviction
and basically risked his entire network
on all of it and is right so far but uh
nobody's always keeping track of any of
that
uh what's the thing that you're looking
for from a milestone basis in 2021 that
would surprise people like what's the
thing that you're paying attention to
that maybe other people aren't
man what a great question um i'm really
paying attention to
um a number of things i'm i'm i'm trying
to i'm really paying attention and a lot
of what our paper focus on
is when retail is going to enter and
there's certain indicators that can
that will show that um if you look at
the amount of active
addresses in the 2017 bull run um they
appreciate it by 60 right now we're
we're at a 18 active at address
appreciation um so i'm looking for
active ad
addresses to hit that level and that'll
be like for me
hey here's an indicator that retails in
and with that you know i you know it
could be an indicator that bitcoin booms
um
i'm also looking at you know the number
of of
whale um wallets as i call them
um these are addresses that have over
five bitcoin
if you look historically um
the number of whale wallets um are at
its top
near the during accumulation phases
right when we're when we're when we're
on the up and run of a bull cycle
when you see the number of whale wallets
decrease that means that
those participants are selling off to
retail and that leads to the active
addresses
increasing right those you know one
leads the other um so that's something
that i'm looking at and
and that can help you you know find the
market top uh you know the best traders
in the world and i
you know we were i've had some amazing
mentors like michael stolzner who heads
up blocker mining
um you know he's he's run he's been in
he has 30 years in
derivatives and runs a company called
futrex um
in the 90s he was the largest euro usd
clearing house
um you know out of the chicago board of
trade and with the chicago board of
trade pit boss so he's taught me a lot
of
grit and and mentality and and also you
can jim ropel who's uh
um you know hedge fund manager and
trader um but but what they'll always
tell you
um and they'll say is you're you're
never gonna hit the bottom perfectly
you're never gonna hit the top perfectly
but follow indicators
um along the way and you know catch
catch catch the wave um
follow the trends you know don't go
against the trends
look for indicators and these are the
type of indicators and things that i
look at
i also look at um you know something you
know i'm a bitcoin mining company as
well which we've you know we haven't
talked too much about but my research
paper is
is not as bitcoin mining focus as you
may think from a company like block
reminding and blockwear solutions right
um but one thing that i'm actually
looking at as well is hash rate
um so something that we're that we're
seeing um that other people may not be
looking at is you know hashrate is
typically a laggard
during bull markets right now and
and we have charts in in the report that
show this but hash rate is is lagging
behind bitcoin price
um so during all these historical cycles
the hash rate
um bitcoin price outpaces difficulty
and for those that understand don't
understand what difficulty is difficult
difficulty is correlated to the total
amount of hash on the market
and that's you know how difficult it is
to mine a bitcoin um so
you know during both cycles i i
anticipate you know miners
to do very well because price typically
outpaces difficulty
um right now hash rate's lagging um so
that that shows me that we're in the
early stages of this full market and i'm
and i'm looking
i'm hyper focused on that um it you know
there hasn't been
two you know a major significant jump
that you know would
would make me think that we're we're
there yet
so is it fair to say 40 000 in 2021 is
just a start
it's just a start and that's the title
of the paper and
and and i will stand by that we're just
at the beginning
man what a frenzy it was i'm sure your
your mailbox blew up
um from december like 15th to like early
january
i mean i i'm still behind on like emails
just like you
are of catching up from you know this
this market frenzy that took place which
is fascinating and i love it um
you know the net capital inflows coming
in institutions and
and and that causes you know a parabolic
rise in bitcoin price
it's absolutely incredible um before i
let you go
uh i got three questions and then you
get to ask me one question
uh the first question is what's the most
important book you've ever read
oh my god that is a great question and
and this is kind of a coordinate answer
but the lord of the rings trilogy like
reading that
you know in my early ages um i i think
like
the what you can learn from a book like
that from a master writer is a lot about
morality um integrity um general
philosophy
and and and just an amazing storyline
that i really just resonated with
um and it you know it's a fascinating
you know series of
love it uh second question is uh from a
sponsor
uh eight sleep they basically do uh
thermoregulation for uh for mattresses
uh it's by far the most comfortable
mattress and also basically
uh now i'm rested all the time because i
sleep on this thing uh
what is your sleep schedule like what do
you like
four hours or ten hours how are you from
as a sleeper
it's funny enough i follow your twitter
i am a minimum
eight hour sleeper and and seriously to
be a high performer and to and to have
your hands in so many baskets and to be
able to get there
i'm usually between eight and ten hours
and that you know i try to go to bed
early
and i try to get up early um try to
exercise um
i i like i like that i like what what's
going on with that company and and it
totally resonates with me
early to bed early to rise leaves a man
healthy wealthy and wise that's what my
dad used to say to me
i love it yeah it looks into your
family's background it's your dad
is a fascinating guy absolutely uh
last question is a little bit more fun
aliens are you believer or non-believer
a total believer and i was laughing like
during the last uh during the last coven
bill that was released like
the like the the uh requests that all
like alien information
is released i forgot the timeline um i
definitely believe her the universe is
way too large of a place um you know
every like literally by the month
there's like more information that
proves that
you know there is life um the problem is
when you're looking you know
deep into the galaxy you're looking at
years past so it's like
if we look at and find something we're
looking at like uh
something that was from year like
millions of years past since like is it
there now like what's going on what
about yourself
uh definitely believe i don't know i
don't know if little green men have come
to earth but uh but but for sure
something out there it's just too big
yeah i agree um all right
so you could ask me one question what do
you got for me
what are your thoughts on bitcoin mining
like i you know i i
i know pomp and pomp is is a bitcoin
evangelist
um in general like what what are your
thoughts on bitcoin mining and
and and you know where do you and you
know my second and trans
transitional thought you know since you
were um calling me out for my forecast
you know
where where do you potentially see big
bitcoin hang
i just stick with the same price
prediction that i've had yeah
i think since like 2019 was 100k in 2021
uh you know that seems pretty reasonable
to me
at the time it wasn't so reasonable
people thought i was a little crazy
they're like how the hell could that
ever happen well you know we're on track
we'll see what happens
uh but the price stuff is like less
exciting to me uh yeah when it comes to
whether it's bitcoin mining um or
actually using you know the protocol
or things of lightning network uh i just
think they were going through a paradigm
shift right
and it's less about like me trying to
convince people anymore it's just like
hey if you can't see what's happening
then like you're just not looking like
you're intentionally trying not to pay
attention at this point
um and so yes there's institutional
adoption happening corporations are
going to do this eventually central
banks will
uh when it comes to mining it's like
anyone in the world with electricity can
start to earn that's a pretty powerful
thing
um and so i think that's pretty cool uh
but same thing is true about now anyone
with internet connection has a payment
network and anyone can exchange value
anywhere in the world with anybody else
without any permission like
that stuff is really really impactful on
a global basis and i think a lot of
people just discount it because they
frankly don't understand it
so uh i got into uh
bitcoin and crypto with mining actually
um
it was with uh gpus and uh and ether
uh i didn't really know what the
difference was all i knew was i just
plug a machine in and like there's cash
flow and like this is basically a data
center on steroids so this is pretty
cool
um and uh and then as you kind of go
down the rabbit hole you're like wait a
minute this bitcoin thing is like
literally
you know once in a lifetime uh type
opportunity and disruption and so i just
naturally gravitate towards it oh that's
all i didn't know that's what led you
into
uh the whole corporate space as well
mining led me into crypto and yeah the
same thing for me i
like in my friend's basement we had a
bunch of gpu buying rigs plugged in we
were mining ethereum
in 2016. and it's cool to hear that you
were part of that
yeah i think bitcoin mining you know you
know is is fundamental to the
success of the network right like you'd
have to turn off
the entire world's power to shut down
bitcoin and that would shut off all the
nodes i mean that's that's a fascinating
output of that
absolutely uh where can we send people
to read more
of the report uh and find more about
both
both companies you have block ware
solutions uh and mining
yeah so blocker solutions.com has all
information about us go to the research
and publication section front and center
top left you'll see
our new report that we just released um
2021 bitcoin market outlook
forty thousand dollars is only the
beginning you can see our historical
research there as well
um blackberry mining um reach out to us
you know from the website if you
want more information there that's an
investment vehicle we take on
institutional and accredited investors
it did really well it launched in
december 2019
you know we caught the early cycle we're
rapidly expanding
um and you know really excited about
what platform mining's potential you
know
with our goal of taking that public um
you know we're already competitive at
penn hash levels and public mining
companies so
i'm really excited about blocker mining
and and uh shout out once again to mike
stolzner and all his work there
absolutely all right my friend thank you
so much for doing this we have to do it
again when you guys write your next
report
all right thanks bob take care and uh
take care everyone look forward to
hearing from many of you after this is
released